>> GREG' LEFTOVERS.
>> Greg: TIME ONCE AGAIN FOR
LEFTOVERS, THIS IS THE SEGMENT
WHERE YOU WATCH ME EAT FOR 40
MINUTES STRAIGHT.
ACTUALLY, IT'S WHERE WE READ THE
JOKES WE DIDN'T USE THIS WEEK.
AND LIKE ANY LEFTOVERS, UNTIL
YOU DIG IN, YOU NEVER KNOW IF
THEY'RE ANY GOOD OR JUST PLAIN
TERRIBLE AND AS ALWAYS, THIS IS
MY FIRST TIME READING THESE.
ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
THIS WEEK DURING AN INTERVIEW ON
NEWS NATION, FORMER CNN ANCHOR
CHRIS CUOMO ANNOUNCED HE
ACCEPTED A JOB AT A FLEDGELING
NETWORK.
I WATCHED A FEW MINUTES DECIDED
HE WAS PRETTY GOOD THEN I
FINISHED FILLING UP MY GAS TANK
AND DROVE AWAY.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: BUT IT WAS NICE TO SEE
NEWS NATION FINALLY BROADCASTER
IN COLOR.
CAN'T HAVE THEM ALL.
CHRIS'S BROTHER ANDREW ALSO
ACCEPTED A NEW TV JOB, I'M
LOOKING FOR HIM ON THE QVC
SELLING HIS NEW BRAND OF NIPPLE
RINGS.
THOUGH HE SAYS THE SENIOR
DISCOUNT WILL NO LONGER BE
AVAILABLE.
BLACK FAMILY SUING SESAME PLACE
ALLEGING SOME OF THEIR COSTUMED
CHARACTERS IGNORED THEIR
DAUGHTER BASED ON HER RACE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID ANY EXCUSE
FOR IGNORING A LITTLE GIRL
DOESN'T PASS THE SNIFF
DEVELOPMENT ALL THIS COMES AFTER
SESAME STREET COULDN'T VERSELY
BLAMED BERT AND ERNIE FOR
SPREADING MONKEYPOX.
THE MAKERS OF GRAND THEFT AUTO
ANNOUNCED THEY'RE RELEASING A
SIXTH VERSION OF THE HIT GAME
NOW WITH THE ABILITY TO PLAY AS
A FEMALE CHARACTER WHICH WILL
MAKE IT EVEN MORE REALISTIC NOW
THAT IT'S A WOMAN CRASHING THE
CAR.
A SEXIST WOULD SAY.
I OWN THAT.
THIS PAST WEEKEND A GROUP OF
NAZI PROTESTERS SHOWED UP
OUTSIDE A TURNING POINT USA
CONVENTION.
ORGANIZERS TRIED TO REMOVE THEM
BUT THEY WERE ON PUBLIC PROPERTY
AND YOU CAN'T TELL THE FBI WHAT
TO DO.
WOW, DING.
THAT'S GOOD.
JET BLUE HAS AGREED TO PURCHASE
SPIRIT AIRLINES FOR
$3.8 BILLION.
AVIATION AND BUSINESS EXPERTS
SAY JET BLUE OVERPAID BY
$3.8 BILLION.
THESE ARE GOOD.
ALSO THE DEAL WAS EXPECTED TO GO
THROUGH IMMEDIATELY BUT IT'S
STILL STUCK IN FORT LAUDERDALE.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THIS WEEK THE NEW YORK
TIMES WROTE ON THE TREND OF
CANNIBALISM AND CONTEMPORARY
FICTION WHICH MEANS THE MEDIA
THINKS WILL SOON BE HUNGRY
ENOUGH TO START EATING EACH
OTHER.
THE GUS INTO I'LL FINALLY GOAT
THAT FIVE STAR MESH LAN RATING
FOR MY APP.
NEW SURVEY FINDS ONE IN THREE
ADMITS STEALING A CO-WORKERS
FOOD FROM THE OFFICE
REFRIGERATOR.
THE OTHER TWO-THIRDS ARE DAM
LIARS KILMEADE.
ACCORDING TO A NEW STUDY, GET
THAT PAPER OFF.
A LOW LA  LA BEAD 0 HAS BEEN
ADDED TO THE LIST OF LONG COVID.
SAID JILL BIDEN THANK GOD
>> THIS WEEK JOHN HINKLY TWEETED
HIS SUPPORT FOR ABORTION.
WHICH IS NOT SURPRISING THAT HE
SUPPORTS KILLING PEOPLE DURING
THE FIRST TERM.
[LAUGHTER].
>> WOW.
>> Greg: THAT IS COLD.
A NEW STUDY CLAIMS THAT DOGSING
WITH WHITE SOUNDING NAMES GET
ADOPTED FROM SHELTERS FASTER
THAN DOGS WITH BLACK SOUNDING
NAMES.
MY DOG ADOLF ALREADY KNEW THAT.
WE'RE THE BEST.
FINALLY SUBWAY RESTAURANTS ARE
OFFERING FREE SANDWICHES FOR
LIFE TO THE FIRST PERSON WHO
GETS A FOOT LONG TATTOO, WHICH
IS A LOT BETTER THAN WHEN JARED
OFFERED FREE SANDWICHES TO SEE
ANYONE'S FOOT LONG.
THOSE ARE PRETTY DAM